well the change may be coming a bit too
late to help boost the raiders into a
postseason bid
but last night las vegas coach john
gruden made a major change on his staff
sports director chris matthews has a bit
more in the monday's raider report
after getting beaten badly by the
indianapolis colts here to legion
stadium last night and losing three of
their last four games
head coach john gruden felt there needed
to be a change made and so
last night he fired defensive
coordinator paul gunther
and replaced him with longtime nfl
veteran rod marinelli
gruden says there just need to be a new
voice in that defensive room
i think he's one of the great teachers
and great
motivators and great people that i've
met in this business
and he looks forward to adversity you
know he thrives in it
um i think he looks forward to these
challenges the
the building of this defense putting it
all together
and that's why we brought him here in
the first place it would certainly help
if his soldiers got healthy up front but
he's got great experience
and has a great amount of experience in
situations like this
well there won't be much time for that
defense or really any of the players or
coaches because this week it's a short
week as the las vegas raiders now
prepare
for the los angeles chargers inside
allegiant stadium coming up on thursday
with the las vegas raiders i'm chris
matthews a sports now